[Música]
bien
en los siguientes minutos
yo quisiera convencerlos de que veamos
con otros ojos
estamos viendo problemas todos los días
hay imágenes como las que tenemos acá
quisiera que levanten la mano quienes
han visto estas imágenes en los últimos
meses
vamos a ver
yo había pensado que más o menos la
mitad creo que un poco más de la mitad y
estas imágenes pues nos dan reacciones
percibimos pero también tenemos acciones
reacciones como las que usamos ahora muy
comúnmente me da la tecnología está
tomando casi el control de nuestras
vidas sobre todo el de los jóvenes y
reaccionamos
por una parte creo que es bueno porque
esas reacciones nos dan conciencia que
es un primer paso
pero yo lo que quisiera proponer es que
vemos uno o dos pasos más y que no nos
quedemos sólo con esa rabia ese
sentimiento de angustia de que el futuro
es oscuro de que no hay futuro incluso
ahora nos estamos llenando creo como
sociedad de muchos de esos sentimientos
negativos y eso a la larga no nos va a
ayudar tenemos que ir más allá y por eso
es que tenemos que ver con otros ojos
el basura charlines como se le está
llamando en guatemala es una muestra de
cómo de estas reacciones ya están
dándose ese paso también algunas
acciones y el que se organicen los
jóvenes para limpiar lugares es algo muy
bueno
tenemos que pensar en esas acciones
individuales en donde pensamos qué puedo
hacer yo en mi casa todos los días pero
también tenemos que pensar
colectivamente
tenemos que pensar como país en cómo
podemos avanzar y mejorar
y ya tenemos ejemplos en nuestro país
también pero también a nivel
internacional sobre cómo los problemas
si vemos algo como un problema y como
eso no solo buscamos soluciones sino
vemos hasta oportunidades
y los desechos sólidos o basura como le
llamamos comúnmente es un ejemplo de
ello dentro de la basura hay muchos
recursos
y estamos usando aluminio vidrio papel
cartón pero en otros países también y en
guatemala y empezamos a tomar lo que se
puede quemar en calderas especializadas
y generar electricidad otros países
generan electricidad y también generan
calor porque son países fríos y
necesitan de ese calor en la temporada
de invierno
otro de los que podríamos ver como
problemas
no quise ser muy gráfico en mi
presentación en otros países también lo
han estado utilizando ya como un recurso
por ejemplo en suecia desde los años 40
han estado extrayendo el metano
se emiten por las aguas residuales de
las ciudades y hoy por hoy lo están
usando como combustible para los buses y
así utilizan el metano de los basureros
también y de otros residuos pero el 40%
proviene de las aguas residuales
entonces de nuevo vemos un problema pero
hay que verlo con ojos de solución que
hacemos y de oportunidad
esta es una foto del río villalobos
a una persona extranjera pero que vive
en guatemala me abrió los ojos una vez y
me dijo sabes cuánto fosfato hay en el
río villalobos el fosfato realmente es
un nutriente para las plantas y está
contenido en los fertilizantes más
utilizados o que es algo que ayuda a los
cultivos a crecer pero el fosfato
también se deriva de los jabones de las
heces fecales y eso en un río
fertilizar las algas que están dañando y
que están contaminando nuestros ríos
entonces esta persona me dijo sabes
cuánto fosfato hay en el río villalobos
que llega al lago de amatitlán yo no
sabía la cifra pero me imaginaba que era
una cifra alta
y él me dijo sabes cuántos quintales de
fertilizante podríamos sacar de ahí
y a mí me dejó con
con mirada de sorprendido verdad porque
yo dije que impresionante ver un río
sucio y en lugar de decir qué triste
somos lo peor en guatemala no cuidamos
etcétera etcétera como es común que
hagamos sino al contrario que veamos
cómo lo limpiamos y a la vez sacamos un
recurso de ahí ese es el tipo de actitud
que yo quisiera dejarles hoy la
inquietud de que tengamos si se puede
aplicar a muchos
en muchas facetas de la vida pero por
supuesto yo quiero usar en tres ejemplos
relacionados al agua y enfocarnos en ese
tema porque es lo que nos tiene reunidos
el día de hoy
problemas de agua y en guatemala eso no
lo podemos negar esta imagen de la gente
con sus toneles con sus botes esperando
camiones que les repartan agua es
bastante común en esta misma ciudad y
también pasa en los otros municipios y
en muchos lugares de nuestro país a
pesar de la abundancia que ya hemos
estado hablando y escuchando
se mueren los cultivos se pierden las
cosechas porque no hay agua para regar
dependemos de la lluvia y eso nos hace
altamente vulnerables porque se atrasan
las lluvias y entonces ya hay pérdidas
lo que llamamos canícula en guatemala
que es cuando llueve menos en la
temporada de lluvia pero si es más
intensa o se extiende un poco y ya
tenemos problemas en guatemala pero es
porque los cultivos no tienen riego
necesitamos el riego para no estar a la
merced de que pase o no con la lluvia
igual con el agua sucia esta foto la
tomé en uno de los pueblos que yo
considero parte de d
en mis orígenes que santacruz de quiché
y este río va a dar al río motagua desde
la parte alta y desde las montañas ya
vemos ese panorama de agua sucia
entonces problemas hay hay escasez
dentro de la abundancia aportando un
poco al lema que estamos usando en este
evento hay escasez dentro de la
abundancia nos podemos preguntar hay
suficiente agua si vemos al país
la verdad es que si uno ve las cifras no
le dicen mucho los números pueden sonar
muy grandes 97 mil millones de metros
cúbicos eso suena muy muy grande pero no
nos dice mucho por eso es que yo estoy
utilizando aquí la comparación con otros
países y si hay países que tienen más
agua que nosotros aquí la comparación es
por habitante
por ejemplo costa rica en nicaragua
tienen cuatro veces más que nosotros
también sus poblaciones son más pequeñas
pero nuestro vecino el salvador tiene la
mitad de agua por habitante y si nos
vamos a países más lejanos como los que
pueden ver españa alemania e incluso un
caso extremo israel 90 metros cúbicos
por persona al año y en guatemala
tenemos 6 mil 875 es una diferencia muy
muy grande pero veamos si en alemania si
en españa o israel hay gente sin agua
veamos si no tienen cultivos
si la industria está limitada al
contrario estos son países que son
potencias y que basan su economía y su
producción y su bienestar en el buen
manejo del agua a pesar de tener mucho
menos que nosotros
y del agua que tenemos en guatemala se
ha estimado que usamos más o menos un
10% hay otros estudios que dicen que
puede ser 20 por ciento pero solo es
para que tengamos una idea entonces
teniendo agua hay escasez en nuestro
país pero si nos preguntamos bueno
tenemos mucha agua pero cuanta
necesitamos en guatemala 150 litros es
una cantidad de estándar en ambientes
urbanos puede ser más hasta 250 en
ambientes rurales es menos según el
informe en guatemala recomienda un rango
entre 90 y 150 litros por persona al día
esto es para cubrir nuestras necesidades
más básicos básicas de higiene consumo
cocinar verdad
y limpiar nuestra casa limpiar la ropa
etcétera todos estos usos cotidianos
necesitamos 150 entonces si vemos la
cifra al año pues nos sale un número
bastante grande son 930 mil metros
cúbicos pero eso como pueden ver en la
gráfica es el 1 por ciento del agua que
tiene el país con ese 1 por ciento del
agua que tenemos podríamos cubrir y que
todos los hogares y todos los
guatemaltecos y guatemaltecas tengan
agua en su casa
nuestro reto es entonces cómo hacemos
para que de verdad tengan agua en su
casa por eso es que se llama se habla de
escasez económica no es una escasez
física sino que es una escasez económica
alta verapaz que es el departamento que
más agua recibe y allá llueve todo el
año en la mayoría del departamento es el
departamento en donde menos hogares
tienen casas tienen agua en sus casas
entonces eso nos llama la atención
también tenemos que considerar que
guatemala tenemos esa gran ventaja de
que produce agua en guatemala por las
montañas por la ubicación geográfica nos
llega agua desde el mar caribe desde el
golfo de mexico y desde el océano
pacifico y entonces aquí nacen muchos
ríos la mitad de esa agua se va por
nuestros ríos hacia méxico un 25 por
ciento se va hacia el mar caribe parte
de esa se va a belice y parte de esa el
otro 25% hacia el océano pacífico
hay ríos que se van a honduras al
salvador entonces podríamos ver a
guatemala como un país exportador de
agua hay otros países que en cambio
dependen del agua de otros países
entonces hay una situación de ahí de
desventaja
entonces aquí quisiera usar tres
ejemplos el primero es la lluvia
la lluvia es agua entregada a domicilio
es agua que literalmente nos cae del
cielo
hoy por hoy nosotros las invisibiliza
mos sobre todo en las ciudades está
lloviendo va a haber más tráfico me voy
a despeinar
se va a inundar una calle no vamos a me
voy a mojar los zapatos se ve hasta como
un problema la lluvia y la lluvia la
deberíamos de ver como un recurso ya lo
ven en otros países
nuestros antepasados lo usaron y
entonces la lluvia realmente es una
fuente que deberíamos de estar
aprovechando por ahí hay unos cálculos
que hice y una casa que tuviera seis
metros de techo 6 metros por 10 metros
con la cantidad de lluvia que cae en la
ciudad de guatemala
podríamos captar más de 80 mil litros en
el año y eso podría alcanzar para tres
meses y medio del agua que se necesita
en una casa asumiendo cinco personas
solo para tener una idea
otro recurso que hay en guatemala en las
montañas no sé si todos saben vamos a
ver si hay gente que quiere el altiplano
que levanten la mano de quetzaltenango
san marcos
levanten la mano yo sé que alguien aquí
de san marcos la neblina que vemos en el
altiplano que nos dificulta conducir
es agua son partículas muy pequeñas de
agua y eso también podemos verlo como un
recurso nosotros en el instituto de
cambio climático hicimos un estudio en
acatenango en donde hay comunidades que
no tienen agua pero neblina hay todo el
año y entonces nosotros medimos cuánta
agua podían capturar con un
atrapanieblas como el que ustedes pueden
observar aquí en la foto y estimamos que
por lo menos podrían ser 3 litros por en
un metro cuadrado entonces
necesitaríamos para una casa en donde
hay cinco personas unos cuarenta y dos
metros cuadrados de esta red para
capturar las gotas no sé si se logra ver
muy bien pero este es un vídeo de ese
atrapar niebla que nos muestra cómo se
está cosechando el agua de la niebla y
va cayendo las gotas y van llenándose
entonces en un recipiente entonces de
nuevo es abrir los ojos hay cosas que
tenemos literalmente en frente y que
podemos utilizarlas
un recurso y el tercer caso y este es un
poco más complejo pero esta foto del río
madre vieja completamente seco la vimos
en el año 2016 esta imagen
se viralizó como se dice ahora
comúnmente se compartió en muchos
lugares y causó mucho
y mucha indignación mucho enojo se
compartió y se empezó a hablar se volvió
una crisis mediática social política e
incluso hubo denuncias y a nivel local
es fue donde empezó este conflicto pero
ese año realmente no era el primer año
en que este río se secaba ya llevaba 25
años de secarse en estos meses enero
febrero en marzo que es la temporada
seca y no se secaba por causas naturales
también juega un papel cuando diez años
con el fenómeno del niño pues llueve
menos eso se reflejan los ríos es un es
un factor pero la razón principal es
que tenemos un problema grave de
gobernanza así le llamamos técnicamente
no tenemos ley no hay autoridad en otros
países se usa el agua porque eso
es algo común pero hay un orden se dan
licencias se dan permisos y entonces
pues no pasa lo que estamos viendo aquí
en esta foto aquí no entonces cuando
empezó y esta es parte de este proceso
tan interesante
que empezó la gente a dialogar al inicio
realmente no parecía diálogo eran
alegatas hay señalamientos quién era el
culpable tal finca tal cultivo tal
comunidad y ese fue un primer buen paso
decir bueno quién tiene la culpa
empezaron a señalar a una empresa pero
cuando se empezó a mapear quién usaba el
agua sólo en la parte baja de este río
se contabilizó y se hizo un mapa con 60
usuarios del agua si habían distintos
cultivos distintas empresas pero también
había comunidades y entonces fue el
primer paso para decir bueno sigamos
hablando lleguemos a acuerdos y
compromisos como los que ven acá
listados lo primero era recuperar el río
y que tuviera agua
y eso se logró en 10 días dejaron todos
de usar el agua y ese río volvió a tener
agua pero entonces se volvió el
compromiso mantengamos con agua el río
y se creó un mecanismo de verificación
porque los acuerdos no sólo tienen que
quedar en papel tienen que hacerse y ya
quedaron de verificar esos acuerdos
crear mecanismos y luego otras otros
acuerdos
uno de los mecanismos de verificación
fue crear un sistema de monitoreo de
ríos entonces que fueran a ver y al
principio iban 60 personas 80 personas
todo mundo quería ir quería ir a medir
querer a ver que había agua en el río no
confiaban en las mediciones de los demás
entonces median ellos dieron unas
caravanas impresionantes de gente yendo
a verificar en el río a medida que esto
evolucionó pues creamos un sistema de
monitoreo todos los puntos rojos que ven
aquí en este mapa son puntos en donde se
va a verificar el nivel de los ríos y
creamos una aplicación que entonces
tenemos siete equipos de medición tres
mandos técnicos al campo ponen todos los
datos de los que están tomando y esta
aplicación y ahí es donde la tecnología
nos puede ayudar y puede ser una
herramienta
y los datos se van directamente a
nuestro servidor entonces pueden estar
en lugares muy alejados pero nosotros a
las 8 de la mañana ya tenemos datos ya
sabemos cómo está el río si vemos que el
nivel está bajando rápido se lanza una
alerta los usuarios del agua se regulan
acuerdan cuánto reducir de lo que están
usando de agua para que el río no se
vuelva a secar
esto ha sido muy exitoso y por eso
quería yo utilizar aquí la oportunidad
esto fue un caso tan exitoso que ahora
se está
llevando a cabo en muchos ríos de la
costa sur
en el caso de madre vieja y achiguate
que fue donde de donde inicio
pues se documentó se hizo un estudio la
cooperación nos apoyó porque dijeron eso
vale la pena documentarlo eso era algo
que la gente local y los que sabíamos de
la complejidad del problema y no nos
imaginábamos que se iba a poder resolver
y no lo sigue diciendo la gente niño
jamás me imaginé que esto se iba a
resolver algún día a pesar de no tener
una ley y de todo lo que se necesita
esos acuerdos locales han ayudado a
llegar ahora a también a noticias
positivas lamentablemente las noticias
positivas no se viraliza como las
negativas pero hay unos cambios
importantes que se están dando en el
país y ahora estamos dando a conocer
esto y en el resto de centroamérica
porque es un avance en gobernanza se
puede mejorar claro y si es necesario
que tengamos las reglas del juego una
ley instituciones etcétera etcétera
pero este es un primer paso muy
importante ya para terminar
yo quería aprovechar la oportunidad
y valerme de de un personaje que ha
tenido mucha influencia en mí
porque él como sabrán aquí la mayoría y
aquí hay una compatriota de nelson
mandela cuando tuvieron el régimen del
apartheid en donde estaba esa separación
tan fuerte entre negros y blancos y él
sufrió en carne propia de esos problemas
pero tenía la visión de que su país
entero saliera de ese problema
y esta cita me dijo mucho verdad de lo
es ese coraje de esa inteligencia y
sabiduría de nelson mandela de decir
para lograr esa visión que yo tengo para
mi país y mi sociedad tengo que dejar de
lado ese resentimiento y ese odio que
pudo haber tenido y liderar a toda una
nación y yo creo que eso es algo muy
inspirador y es algo que no surge en
guatemala que veamos el problema del
agua que veamos el problema de la
desnutrición y tantos otros que podemos
mencionar y que si tenemos una visión de
largo plazo y para todo el país y
dejamos de lado todas esas cargas tan
fuertes que tenemos encima lo podemos
lograr si una persona lideró ese
movimiento en su país
creo que en guatemala también lo podemos
lograr muchas gracias
[Aplausos]
[Música]